so I want you to think about it you got
a product or service you're trying to
sell and this is you the person that's
trying to market your product and this
is the decision maker not to get from
here to here you're gonna have to go
through gatekeeper other people that you
need to go through before you get here
too many times folks can't get the
product to the decision maker because
their approach is creepy stalkerish you
know they don't know how to get there
and these people are saying no to you
but not this person you need to get to
this person them saying no if they say
no it's a legitimate no but not to get
here is a real challenge so today we're
gonna talk about how you can get a hold
of anyone so before I get into today's
episode if you're watching back to me
for the very first time this is the
first video you've ever watched on by
attainment and if you haven't subscribed
to the channel do so we have a lot of
different episodes on money
entrepreneurship sales raising money and
a lot of unique episodes be sure to
subscribe to go watch the other content
but let me get right into it how to get
a hold of any one point number one when
I'm coming up I'm trying to get a hold
of anybody I'm trying the 7 approach
philosophy 7 contact philosophy the goal
is to try to get ahold of the person
you're trying to get ahold of in seven
different ways too many times people do
one way email oh my gosh she didn't get
back to me Leyton how come he didn't get
back to me I send them a tweet why
wouldn't you reply to my tweet I left
them a message how come he didn't
respond back to my message you should be
getting back to my message you have to
be in the person's world that you're
trying to get ahold of the person's
world is busy you are one of many people
that are trying to get ahold of them you
have to be unique and you have to be
more persistent than the other guy and
still not seem creepy for example say
you send an email in its person you
trying to get ahold of it's a CEO and
they get 600 emails a day you're one of
600 emails what do you think your rank
and priority okay
so let's just say you send me a message
on Twitter and the message is like
thousands of tweets or hundreds of
tweets you're one of hundreds everything
to use odds right but then if you go
research this person that you're trying
to get ahold of all their different
accounts you'll notice on Instagram they
only have 1,100 followers and they post
regularly which means they're actively
getting on their Instagram account once
a day minimum two three times a day but
they don't necessarily have a lot of
followers which means if you DM them
there
see you so now you got an email one in
600 tweet one in 500 DM one in five the
chances of them seen your message is 20%
on Instagram than it is on all the other
ones so this is why you reach out on
Instagram let me give you a couple
stories of where this is going
yesterday I was doing my monthly private
elite webinar this is for people that
qualify and I spend an hour and a half
with them with SEOs entrepreneurs and
startup founders and we go through areas
to process one of the entrepreneurs from
Costa Rica asks a question they run a
big company that does green their focus
on green energy and he is trying to get
a hold of these people in America to
presented them how they make their
company more green right so Patrick I'm
having a hard time getting ahold of all
these folks these c-suite executives I
said okay when you say c-suite
executives how many artery says oh it's
so many it's gonna take me so long to
get a hold of all of my said really
I said added a CEO CEO CMO CIO CTO who
are you trying to get a hold of he says
well it's only the CIO that's it really
chief information officer yes that's
what I'm trying to get a hold of I said
okay how many companies are there that
you're targeting
he says it's exactly a hundred companies
I said what you mean to tell me is
really only a hundred at CIOs you trying
to get a hold of he said yes I said
seriously that's not a lot of people I
said you got to make a list of all these
hundred figure out there platforms find
ways to get a hold of each one of them
tailor a message to them mail him
something send them something email them
Instagram them LinkedIn them tweet them
and then at the end call them because by
the time you call them they've already
gotten all this different information
sent to them and they're gonna know that
you've done your part right and he says
I never thought about it that way before
I said 100 CIOs but if you're wanting to
be part of the private monthly webinar
we're gonna put a link below to
questionnaire you got an answer to
qualify for it and then you can possibly
invite it to a put the link below so you
can go fill out the information for so
this guy this CEO of Costa Rica is gonna
reach out to 100 CIOs about his product
right now it doesn't mean all of them
are gonna do anything to have a good
product it's got of a good approach but
let me give you another personal story
ten years ago I'm not on social media
ten years ago I'm not on social media I
don't have a YouTube platform
don't have a facebook fanpage I'm not
active on Twitter at all I'm not doing
nothing with social media I'm a private
guy ten years ago and I decide to write
a book it's called 25 laws for doing the
impossible right should I write this
book and I said here's what we're gonna
be doing we made a list of 1,000 sales
leaders real estate insurance
investments it does pharmaceutical sales
anybody that was a 7 figure earner we
made a list of a thousand and then we
can find this list it's not hard to find
this list a thousand of them we mailed
two books of these copies two books to
the influencer one for him because a lot
of times influencers will get a book
that's all you read it give it to the
assistant so we sent two and I said one
is for your assistant one is for you if
you're too busy have them read it if you
can you read them but actually I feel
this is gonna be a good good book for
your organization perfect we know that
send a little follow-up to them all of a
sudden you know what happens two months
later we get an order from Russia for
75,000 copies to buy this book and in
two thousand a thousand five thousand
ten thousand one hundred fifty thousand
copies of a book was sold in year one
I have zero social media presence
literally zero social media presence
when this book came out how did that
happen it's the approach it's the
marketing gets going to them not waiting
for people to come to you so number one
of getting ahold of anybody is this 7
contact philosophy number to find out
the 5 people they respect the most so
say for instance I am NOT responding
back to you but you find out through
blog I wrote or a video I talked about
or youtube I did or an interview I did
or podcast I did I mentioned 10 names
okay that are my mentors people I admire
my father my dis my dad they don't have
the influence that I have or the person
you're trying to get ahold of right it
is easier to get ahold of them you find
a way to win them over contact them and
win them over when they find out that
you have a relationship with them when
you reach out to them and say the other
day I spoke to John Doe who is one of
the mentors you mentioned in a podcast
we had a very good conversation together
and I was able to help him out with a
couple
other things but I wanted to figure out
a way to speak to you about a matter
that I think could benefit you right
first thing I'm gonna do is when I see
this message I'm gonna be like wait a
minute what's he doing talking to my
mentor as someone's respectful my mentor
I'll respond back to this because it's
essentially we spawn him back to my
mentor because his name's on the line I
have more weight in getting back to you
because of this name than anybody else
if that makes sense to you so get the
five people that they respect the most
win them over you'll win them over
typically number three show up in person
when I did my first big insurance deal
it was a seven billion dollar company I
had nothing going on we had no insurance
contract zero everyone saying no to me I
kept every wanted their answers on a
three by five card to have it till today
no no no no no finally I said you know
what instead of doing this I'm showing
up in person I went I sat in the front
lobby I flew up from California you're
not from here no I flow from California
and I'm in Iowa I knew he was in I want
to have a 30-minute conversation with
him I'll wait because I've got to be
able to meet with this gentleman I got
something I have to speak to him about
and I was referred to by such-and-such
wait a minute you really can't I said
yeah I told him an email I was gonna fly
out because he told me he's in town but
he told me he's busy I'm just you even
if I get a 15 30 minute conversation I
want to have that with them they sat
there and they said if this guy is that
persistent to be willing to fight to
meet with me he is gonna be that
persistent to make sure he runs a good
quality business let's meet with them
boom that's exactly I struck my first
deal by going in person face to face
right so show up in person number four
have someone who knows you and knows
them send a note to them for example you
are trying to get a hold of Bobby Bobby
is a very successful businessman he's
gonna be a good account for you but you
also know me and he is not getting back
to you you asked me because we have a
relationship saying hey Pat can you ask
Bobby to just look at that email respond
mark I just need 10 minutes of his time
then you have to convince me because I'm
gonna be like well I don't know you know
it's just I'm but patty this is what I'm
doing okay you know what this sounds for
let me get him hey then I call him and I
say Bobby can you do me a favor call
that guy but he Pat send me seven emails
I get it just called I think it's got
something I could benefit from you look
if you don't want it 10 minutes later
just let him go but I think it's a guy
you ought to talk to give him 10 minutes
of my time perfect so you see how I'm
you
boom contact here's they call you back
very simple that's step number four
number five when the layers of
protectors every person the more
influential they are a lot of times have
a lot of layers of protectors very few
times like a Mark Cuban doesn't use
protectors you can go direct to him he
responds back to his email to cyberdust
but sometimes there's a lot of people
that have protectors you have to win
them over winning them over is just as
important as winning the main person
over how do you win them over that's the
creative side of what you need to do to
win them over
creativity helps a lot to get to that
level number six study their world I'll
give you a perfect example would let me
study their world so I was in New York
two days ago two days ago three days ago
I was in New York some like that I was
in New York three days ago and I went to
New York and had a meeting with for
investment bankers okay these are for
the very well-known investment bankers
that people know the names they know the
companies they know people know who
these guys are so I wanted to the
meeting first meeting second meeting
third meeting fourth meeting first
meeting unbelievably impressive he knew
everything about us second meaning the
guy knew everything about us third
meeting we go meet with this guy and
he's sitting there he has no clue what
he's talking about nothing he tried to
do the sales main connection which is
like all he did you know like I have
family that's also Middle Eastern all
this others I'm like that's nice but
what do you know about our business
model and what we're doing in who some
of the people that you know that we
could always buy to acquire do some kind
of business with and this guy's gonna
make a lot of money on this it's not
like a fifty thousand dollar commission
check this could end up being a million
two million three million dollar
commission check for this guy's not a
small Commission chicks a big Commission
check he didn't do any research he just
kind of said well you know this this and
I asked some pointed questions for tell
me about what you would think about this
and we we think about that general
general general general general answer
lightweight the other three specific one
of them unbelievably specific who do you
think's getting the business they
studied the world
one guy wind it if you just study the
world a little bit that shows respect
for the person that you wanted to do
business with they sit there saying if
this person studied us this much I can
only imagine how much it's gonna study
the other people that we want to do
business with this is the kind of guy
one
the businessman and have no problem
paying this guy to $3,000,000 a
commission for doing the business that
we want him to do study there world
number seven make a personal video for
them let me explain to what I mean by
this the other day this was about two
months ago we got this package sent from
an Emily Hirsch okay
comes in the team opens up the packages
before it comes to me maybe 5% at a time
I see what's sent maybe five to ten
percent time I I see what some but the
team walks and says Pat you got to take
a look at this very creative watch this
look what she made personalized tom
complimentary studied their world
perfect happy smile likable now it's the
introduction so you see where she's
going what she specializes with so you
see what she's saying right she sent
this message and I see it I'm impressed
I'm like oh very impressive let's follow
up with her the team calls they get on
the phone everything is good she got our
attention by the way watch this now a
hundred emails you send out versus
something like that what do you think is
gonna get more attention that cost
twenty five bucks but a hundred emails
is what everybody does one thing like
that get someone's attention like oh my
gosh I've never seen that before
matter of fact if you see it right now
yourself you're thinking about how do I
go out there and do this we can put the
link before and who does something like
this not hard to find him you can go out
and do business with them moral the
story is this is very creative and
different and it's personalized I'll get
emails and somebody will say Pat I
follow your content it's phenomenal I
got a personalized video on five things
you can do to increase your Instagram
followers ship or increase your Facebook
or increase your Twitter and increase
your YouTube increase exposure increase
fun anything that's a here's number one
number two I notice you're not doing
this I noticed this on number three look
I'd like to do more for if you give us a
call back those types of people we will
typically talk to not saying everybody
because after saying this on the video
we're gonna get bombarded with a bunch
of different things it's not everybody
but it's a higher percentage for you of
getting somebody want to do biz
with you now everything I said here
everything I said here means nothing
everything na think unless if you don't
follow up means nothing you know why
because after the conversation we have
with Emily Hirsch every time somebody
does something with me we always finish
it off with homework on their end always
because it shows me their discipline
read this book first and then I'll do
this for you read this thing first then
I'll do this for you watch this video
first and I'll do this for you when they
don't do to follow up they also want you
to follow up when you hire them
the unfortunate thing with Emily Hirsch
was she send that we gave her a
challenge on a follow-up we never heard
back from her never heard back from her
look how much time she put into the
energy but she never got back what are
we gonna do with Emily what kind of
business are we gonna do she didn't
follow up the people that did they are
now doing the contract for the vault
conference okay
that's coming up do you realize the
commission for the people that got the
vault conference is gonna end up being
somewhere between three to seven hundred
thousand dollars of commissions to them
that could have been her account but she
didn't follow up she lost that account
many of us have lost accounts i've lost
accounts because of lack of follow but
i'm just telling you right now as a
person that's been in this business for
a while this has caused people billions
of dollars simply because they do the
front-end work good follow up bad they
lose business so the point is whatever
you do here means nothing unless if you
don't follow if you're disciplined
enough to follow up eventually business
is gonna work for you so if you watch
this you got a lot of value out of it
you may want to watch it again but i got
a second video i want you to watch it's
a video i did a couple years ago about
guerrilla marketing 14 tactics of
guerrilla marketing very creative these
are ways that i use throughout my career
that has to do a little bit about this
because it's creative click on this
thumbnail here or we'll put the link
below as well to go watch the video if
you haven't subscribed do so if you got
any thoughts comment below thanks for
watching everybody take care bye bye
you